وفي سوريا قال مراسل الجزيره الى مساعدات
مقدمه من اليونسيف لمتضرري زلزال شمال
غربي سوريا دخلت من معبر باب السلامه شمال
حلب كما قالت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود ان
قافله مساعدات من اربع عشره شاحنه دخلت
شمال غربي سوريا للاسلامي في عمليات
الاغاثه من الزلزال
هذا وكان موفدون من الامم المتحده تفقدوا
مدينه جندريس شماليه سوريا لتقديم
المساعدات الاغاثيه بعد الزلزال هذه
البلده توصف بانها من اكثر المناطق تضررا
في الشمال السوري
من جهه اقاله وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه
للالتلاف السوري المعارض ان اكثر من 55
الف شخص نزحوا الى الملاجئ ليضافوا الى
اكثر من 20000 كانوا يقيمون في ملاجئ قبل
الزلزال بسبب الحرب
ومعنى الان من معره مصرين في ريف ادلب
مراسل الجزيره ادهم ابو الحسن ادهم اذا
الانظار كلها على الشمال السوري الان
وامكانيه دخول المساعدات المحتاجه جدا
بالنسبه للمتضررين
ما هي اخر المعلومات بهذا الشان
نعم المنطقه اليوم تترقب وصول قافله
مساعدات عموميه ستدخل من معبر باب الهوى
الحدودي مع تركيا هي عباره عن قافله مؤلفه
من عشرين شاحنه تحمي المساعدات انسانيه
وكان قد سبقها منذ اليوم الخامس للزلزال
الذي ضرب منطقه شمال غرب سوريا عده قوافل
امميه ايضا منها ما كان هو مدرج ضمن
البرنامج الاعتيادي لتقديم الدعم للنازحين
والمهجرين في هذه المنطقه ومنها ما هو
جاءك استجابه طارئه تحمل اجهزه ومعدات
طبيه ومولدات كهرباء ايضا اذا اردنا
الحديث عن مجمل او اجماليه المساعدات
الامميه التي قدمت الى هذه المنطقه بعد
الزلزال نستطيع ان نتحدث عن اكثر من 120
شاحنه مساعدات امنيه اضافه الى اكثر من
130 شاحنه من منظمات خيريه دخلت مع منظمه
الاغاثه التركيه الى داخل الحدود مع تركيا
ولكن كميه الاحتياجات كبيره جدا نت عن
الاف العائلات التي ما زالت حقيقه في وضع
انساني سيء حتى هذه اللحظه نحن في احد
مراكز الايواء هو واحد من ثمانيه وستين
مركز ايواء في شمال غرب سوريا يتم
الاستجابه للعائلات المشرده في العراء
والتي تبيت في العراق يتم الاستجابه لهم
هنا بشكل مؤقت ربما فتره اقامتهم هنا
تستمر لثلاثه ايام او اربعه ايام لينتقلوا
فيما بعدها الى
مخيمات ربما تكون اكثر تنظيما تؤمن لهم
بعض الخصوصيه والاستقلاليه مجهزه بمرافق
خدميه اما هنا في هذا المركز فاليه العمل
هي استجابه طارئه النساء والاطفال في قسم
والرجال والشباب في قسم اخر اي ان العائله
لا ترى بعضها الا في ساعات قليله خلال
ساعات النهار اما اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
الوضع الطبي او القطاع الصحي فالى الان ما
زال القطاع الصحي عليه ضغط كبير بسبب
تداعيات هذا الزلزال نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من
6000 اصابه
خرجوا من تحت ركام هذا الزلزال وهم بحاجه
الى رعايه طبيه وايضا عمليات جراحيه
متتابعه فيما يخص من تعرضوا لبتر اطراف
وايضا الى من تعرضوا الى اصابات وعائيه
وعصبيه لا سيما ان الجانب التركي ما زال
مغلق معبر باب الهوى امام الحالات المرض
المرضيه سواء البارده او الطارئه حتى هذه
اللحظه تحدث عن حجم احتياجات كبيره
وتداعيات مستمره الى هذه اللحظه واهمها
كما ذكرنا العائلات التي ما زالت في وضع
انسان سيء وايضا المصابين والجرحى الذين
يحتاجون لرعايه طبيه فائقه نعم
اذا وضع ماساوي على العموم غطيت زوايا
كثيره ادهم ابو الحسام ولكن لا يكفي مهما
قلنا وصف حجم هذه المعاناه التي يمر بها
هؤلاء شكرا جزيلا لك على